we've been given rare access to these
islands off the coast of northumberland
visitors here have been banned since
birds began dying in their thousands
rangers first detected avian flu here
eight weeks ago at the start of nesting
season teams who normally count new
chicks have now the grim task of
collecting their remains
devastating
we have already picked up thousands of
dead birds
and that is probably just the tip of the
iceberg there are many birds that will
be at sea
that have died or along the coast
which is very hard to quantify
everyone's wearing protective gear to
prevent cross-contamination
within an hour of work these rangers
tell us they've collected 300 dead
guillemot chicks and then they'll just
die there which is really sad
as the day goes on it gets worse
the teams that are working here say they
have never seen such a devastating
outbreak of avian flu every time they
come to these islands they are leaving
with bag upon bag of dead bird carcasses
the impact it's just horrendous these
cliff top birds are at the end of their
breeding period there should be young
fledglings ready to start migrating and
instead what you're seeing instead on
these cliff tops are dead birds like
this
around six thousand wild birds have died
just on these islands but this outbreak
has affected seabird colonies across the
uk it's hit poultry farms too on the
mainland affecting prices of poultry
products what seems to be quite
prominent about this crisis that we're
facing
is
it's just a manner of different species
that are affected by it
you know can have previously you might
you might tend to find that more
individual
uh species are just gilly motors or
turns might be affected by different
diseases but this one seems to be
a little bit more indiscriminate
avian flu outbreaks occur almost
annually but this year's strain seems
more deadly than ever
the government says it is supporting
farmers
but conservationists here say there
needs to be more funding for wild bird
research to establish why this is
happening and to save the lives of these
beautiful birds in the seasons to come
caterina totsi sky news on the farn
islands